man merkt halt im gefängnis erst richtig
zeit ist und das geld eigentlich nicht
aufzuwerten ist wie ist das wenn das
alte leben plötzlich endet und das neue
hier stattfindet hinter gittern und das
für eine sehr lange zeit
man isst man ist schon ein bisschen
schneller gereizt
habe ich dieses umfeld hier dann sind ja
auch viele
ja wir sollten den man draußen
eigentlich nichts zu tun
die größte herausforderung in der jva in
ummeln bloß in keinen streit geraten
nicht auffallen hier sitzen männer mit
besonders langen strafen die jahre
könnten sonst sehr ungemütlich werden
freundschaften sind hier selten
von meinen von manchen kann mein wissen
freunde war merkt man später draußen das
ist doch keine war also im gefängnis ist
die freundschaft müssen anders auch rein
brust raus rücken gerade der jva-beamte
riedmann passt auf dass es hier nicht
zum streit kommt und macht mit den
männern sport um aggressionen abzubauen
welche einsetzt hat eine lange zeit im
geschlossenen vollzug hinter sich und
muss sich nun im offenen beweisen dass
die gefangenen dürfen auch raus in die
normale welt ein paar stunden die woche
jetzt verschiedene gefangenen mit
verschiedenen delikten von erschleichen
von leistungen also schwarzfahren über
schwere gewalttaten über
straftaten im sexuellen bereich bis mord
sitzt ihr quasi alles mario wegen drogen
handeln
erst im nachhinein so fing das findet
man das einst realisieren und man dann
bei der polizeiwache in der zelle drin
war und
dann vor den haftrichter kommen und dann
hat sich die erste nacht im
geschlossenen verbracht habe dann ja
dann hat man realisiert er hat seine
freiheit verloren
sie stehen unter ständiger beobachtung
dürfen sich nichts mehr zu schulden
kommen lassen sonst geht es zurück in
die geschlossene abteilung ihre größte
angst
ich war sechs monate und schafft dort
komplett durchgerissen stadt noch
gereicht
fast vier jahre
man fühlt sich schon einsam name
weist du
aber man wird doch gleichzeitig ein
bisschen ruhiger im geschlossenen ist
nicht mal eben zu hause anrufen das
zweimal hin zweimal monatlich besuch
für eine stunde ja und das war es dann
auch noch das ist im offenen vollzug
anders das will er nicht mehr aufgeben
und eigentlich ständig mit der angst
einen falschen tritt und du bist weg
gerade über lang strafen jetzt dürfen
sie gestaffelt immer mehr raus aus dem
gefängnis sich auf dem gelände bewegen
und viele haben einzelzimmer
quadratmeter
es sind kleine freiheiten die er zu
schätzen weiß wie ein schlüssel für
seinen haftraum von unterschied also
niemanden also ein bediensteter innen
die tür aufschließt und man hinter hin
zu schließen und sie kommen nicht mehr
raus die beamten können aber jederzeit
reinkommen
ja eigentlich hat man hier keine
privatsphäre hier
kommen die jederzeit rein und
durchsuchen ein
die die hütte
das hier ist sein zuhause für die
nächsten jahre hier ist mir zusammen am
tisch denn im offenen vollzug dürfen
sich gefangenen fast zu jeder zeit in
den zimmern besuchen
trotzdem obwohl dennis schon lange im
gefängnis sitzt man gewöhnt sich daran
sagt er die regeln und verbote zum
beispiel dafür am ausgang ein frisches
fleisch einkaufen salmonellengefahr
jetzt ist da vegetarier
wer gegen mehrere verbote verstößt und
vor allem wer gewalttätig wird landet
hier auf ihrer zellen die tür ist dann
zu
also das ist diese sogenannte abgangs
abteilung hier werden alle gefangenen wo
feststeht dass sie nicht mehr im offenen
vollzug geeignet sind die werden dann
hier untergebracht wer noch weiter
eskaliert muss hier ein jetzt befinden
uns in einer so genannten schlicht zelle
wir schon sehen kannst hier sind die
möbel das mobiliar ist verschraubt auch
hier unten an den bänken und tischen ist
man halt keine möglichkeit hat den raum
zu verbarrikadieren toilette und
waschbecken wird aus metall spiegel
nicht aus glas und wir haben die
möglichkeit über kamera den raum 24
stunden zu beobachten wenn das nicht
reicht droht diese zelle
also hier landen wirklich noch die
gefangenen die akkus ideal sind
die sehr aggressiv gegen gefangene
bedienstete oder sich selber sind
wo man halt ausschließen muss dass die
gefangenen sich selbst verletzen in
dieses gefängnis kommen außerdem alle
gefangenen bevor sie in der jva
weiterverteilt werden bielefeld senne
ist europas größter offener vollzug
es gibt eine gefängnis gärtnerei
tischlerei wäscherei auch durch die
arbeit sollen die gefangenen auf das
leben danach vorbereitet werden
dennis repariert die bäder in allen 17
gefängnissen der jva
schon ganz gut dass man ganzen tag der
beschäftigung hat
hier sind sollen zwei toiletten
verstopft seien
die haben andere brücker platten drauf
damit da damit will dahinter nicht
verstecken können damit die bediensteten
immer noch angucken können
die arbeit lenkt dennis ab auch von
seiner tat über die öffentlich auf
keinen fall genauer sprechen
und ich hab mir nach hilfe gesucht um
was zu verarbeiten
sein kompagnon kommt wohl früher heraus
als er auch das macht es nicht einfacher
im gefängnis klar man verliert einen
guten kumpel in der
mine wie man nicht so viel dennis denkt
trotzdem weiter nur 1 1 die entlassung
irgendwann und mario ja ich wünsche mir
einfach ein
friedliches leben
wir reisen wir sehen
einfach mit meiner frau eine tolle zeit
vermeiden das leben eines schnell vorbei